I uh on Monday afternoon I appeared on
Piers Morgan's show and we talked about
as we've discussed in the show here the
viral trend of women trying to entrap
men at the gym by filming them and
pretending that the men were harassing
them and I made one point that
scandalized one of the feminists on the
panel and uh let's listen to that
I don't think you could avoid looking at
people because I'm looking up to see
what their forms like how they're
carrying certain weights are they
carrying more than me you know male or
female I don't really care I'm just I'm
quite curious about other people using a
gym am I now going to be something
appearing on Instagram the influence
influences sites is some sort of perv
well it's possible and look by the way I
also I don't mean to be a victim blamer
here but but could we also say that if
you're a woman and you don't want to you
don't want men to notice you in the gym
maybe wear more than your underwear to
go work out I mean these women whose
videos they're wearing sports bras and
like hot pants I mean how about put some
clothes on if you don't want people to
look at you this is victim blaming no
I'm sorry
Atwood here that uh men are afraid of
women laughing at them women are afraid
that men are going to kill them it is
not okay to say that it's a woman's
fault for wearing the wrong you think
the people looking over at people using
some equipment a gym are going to kill
them I think that taking photographs is
threatening staring at people is
photographing it are these Instagram
influencers they are videoing men taking
photographs of them and listening
victim victim we hit the the Margaret
Atwood quote there
um
and and and actually just so you know
uh men the the big fear that men have
when it comes to women especially women
who try to do exactly what these women
in the gym are doing
um the fear is not being laughed at the
the fear is being publicly shamed it's
being falsely accused it's having your
life and reputation destroyed
being laughed out to your face who cares
about that
the fear is reputational destruction
and that is a power that women wield
much more than men
okay an accusation from a man in our
society doesn't carry a lot of weight
but we know we've heard the the slogans
believe all women believe women and we
also know that the people that say that
you know there are plenty of women that
they don't want to believe such as the
woman that accused Joe Biden of sexual
assault but
that's the slogan anyway
so one woman says something and your
life is destroyed that is the fear for
men and it's a it's a valid fear
um and having your entire life and
reputation destroyed is a is a
major tragic event it's not simply being
laughed at
but I know that I said kind of
facetiously I don't mean to victim blame
but fine I am victim blaming okay if if
uh we're talking about someone who is a
woman who is the victim she's the victim
of a man looking at her if that's the
kind of victimization we're talking
about a man looking at you if that makes
you a victim if that makes you a victim
then yes I blame you if you're walking
outside of your house in your underwear
uh yes that you you have made yourself
the victim
by doing everything in your power to
attract the male gaze not just the male
gaze but anyone's gays
because as I said when we talked about
this last week if I walked out of the
house of my underwear If any man walked
out of the house people would stare at
us
they might not stare
uh in a in a sort of pleased way but
they would still be staring
whether they're horrified and grossed
out or whatever whatever the reason for
saying they be staring because they'd be
thinking why look at that person in
their underwear
let's just say that's a normal human
response when you walk around in your
underwear
if that makes you a victim to be the
object of someone's gaze okay if that's
the kind of victimization we're talking
about then yes you deserve the blame for
it you deserve actually 100 of the blame
for it
if you're walking around your underwear
um if you're dressed in a way that is
that is designed
to attract people's gaze
and then you get exactly what you're
what you were hoping for
yes the blame goes to you
uh without question
and there's a pretty easy solution here
which is to put on clothes and also
it does make me question you know I know
we hear from the feminists women walk
around all the time terrified that a
man's going to kill them
is that
you walk around your underwear like
wearing your underwear to the gym that's
the behavior of a woman who's afraid
she's going to be killed by a man
that if you're afraid of men and that's
how you respond
now this that to me seems like the
behavior of someone who has no fears at
all that's just that someone who's
utterly oblivious and not afraid of
anything and that'll do it for this
portion of shows and move over to the
members block if uh you want to become a
member you can do that now by using Code
wall should check out for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]